Build It.
Draw It.
Play It.
Vsauce!
Kevin here with some of the coolest creations
from extraordinary people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build It.
Choe U-Ram builds kinetic insect lamps.
The shiny biomorphic insects flutter and glow
using motors and LEDs.
And he considers his moving sculptures to
be living things - in which every piece has
its place and after it eventually breaks down
- the pieces can be dismantled and reused
as a type of rebirth.
Lori Nix makes post-apocalyptic dioramas.
She meticulously builds landscapes and architectural
interiors and then photographs them without
any digital manipulation.
And she mixes a wide variety of materials
like foam board, clay, paper, acrylic paint,
plaster, wood, tiny figurines and organic
materials like real leaves punched through
leaf-shaped holes.
And she creates them in her small apartment
in New York City.
Kendra Haste creates huge animals out of galvanized
wire.
She goes on wild expeditions like tracking
tigers in India or following wildebeest migrations
in Tanzania and then makes the sculptures
based on individual animals she encounters.
The unique portraits are drawn on paper and
then matched with wire and brought into the
third dimension.
Draw It
Josiah Brooks makes animations, tutorials,
and speed paintings on his YouTube channel
Draw With Jazza.
The Australian will teach you everything from
painting in Photoshop to different animating
techniques like how to animate a transformation.
He even has a series of videos just about
the creative process to provide advice and
motivation for budding artists.
Judith Braun creates wall murals by fingerpainting
with charcoal dust.
She explores symmetrical designs as well as
textured landscapes.
Though Braun typically painstakingly plans
her pieces in advance she was recently diagnosed
with breast cancer which has influenced her
to take a more improvisational approach to
her work.
And she abides by three rules - Symmetry,
Abstraction and Carbon medium.
And now for the hyper-collage architecture
of Jim Kazanjian.
made from up to fifty composited images.
Mike Kravanis is a bento box fanatic and focuses
his food creations mostly on Disney-inspired
food characters.
His Instagram account OMGiri showcases dozens
of colored-rice creations ranging from Tigger
and Professor Ratigan to a few non-Disney
creations like Princess Bubblegum and PuppyCat.
Play It.
Polynoid director Jan Bitzer used a setup
of laser and mirrors to animate Islands of
Glass by Barcelona musician Rob Clouth.
SamuraiGuitarist makes inventive guitar-based
videos.
Here’s his version of Kentucky Jelly by
Brad Paisley using a banjo, telecaster, acoustic
guitar, washboard and spoons, mandolin and
acoustic bass.
Finally, the video for Raiders by French band
Soundcrawler draws from Star Wars, Dune and
Mad Max.
Inspiration also comes from you.
Vsauce Creative Fan Showcase.
First up is Eddef with Early Winter Morning.
Let’s go!
Jordan Clayton is a Canadian visual artist
that specializes in paintings that focus on
the science and understanding of phenomena.
His most recent work explores fungal and bacterial
growth.
David Lechner creates wooden sculptures using
driftwood pulled out of a local river in Austria.
The 17-year-old began a carpentry apprenticeship
and has since been using his newfound skills
to create sculptures.
Here’s the digital photography of Shaheer
Akbar.
Naisu performs three original songs behind
the San Diego Convention Center.
Wes was paralyzed from the neck down during
a motocross accident and uses a Headmouse
Extreme to create designs for his clothing
brand 4ONE7.
Emiel Sleegers is a 3D environment artist
from the Netherlands - he hopes to get a full-time
job in the gaming industry and recently recreated
part of the University environment from The
Last Of Us.
While over in Australia, Daniel Rutherford
designs and models mecha, weapons, characters
and other sci-fi stuff with 3ds max.
Leo Freidrich has a series of daily improv
piano videos - here’s his take on M83, Rihanna
and Imagine Dragons.
Stefan Perse is an architect from Romania
who bends copper wire into different creations
and he just recently completed this set of
copper insects.
And Bonny John drew a pokemon a day - often
using completely different styles - and you
can find the complete set on his website.
Submit your BiDiPis to BiDiPi@Vsauce.com or
share them with everyone over on Twitter with
hashtag #BiDiPi.
And as always - thanks for watching!